138 kentuckians uh went to the emergency
room
shortly
during or or after the the tornado
we do not have uh numbers right now on
how many
remain
and or their condition
yesterday
yesterday we had a visit from the
president of the united states
you know we here in kentucky
have felt uh the love and support of the
entire country
and of the entire world
you know walking through it yesterday
and actually being able to get further
back in dawson springs
the devastation
is still
i don't know if the right word is
profound
traumatic um painful
especially from a
for me from a town that's was your safe
place
growing up here is
mayfield
but we have despite all that pain
felt the love
president united states
secretary of homeland security
the administrator for fema
all personally reached out the vice
president and so many others and they
committed
and then
we not only saw it in the fastest
emergency declaration that i'm aware of
ever
in history of the united states and the
fastest major declaration ever
president united states who's
got a lot on his plate came down
to see us
to look at us
in the eye
and to tell us that not only was he
going to be here for the years to come
which is exactly what
i needed and we needed to hear
but that he cared about us
the people of both mayfield and dawson
springs
i could tell
saw that
um
people that
know my dad well
who were there right in the line of the
tornado um getting to talk one-on-one
to the president
we appreciate him being here
it showed a a level of dedication
and he showed a level of care
for for us
and i want to make sure that this visit
is only viewed the way it should
as support that we are grateful for
and while he was here
he even made some more news
stepped up doing yet another uh thing
that
you almost never see
but it's going to help us even more
on tuesday evening i submitted
a request to the president for the
federal government to cover a hundred
percent of the costs
of some of the the specific costs of
recovery from the tornadoes for our
first 30 days of digging out
i did this
um
hoping
but knowing even the
75-25 share which is what it normally is
with the federal government paying 75
and the state and the county really
splitting the 25 percent the county pays
a little bit more but knowing that's
hundreds upon hundreds of millions of
dollars and so we asked for what would
almost be the unthinkable can you the
federal government just pay for all of
certain costs to help us
on wednesday
the president
told me personally
the answer was yes
he actually said when the request came
in he didn't know if he had the legal
authority to do it and turns out he did
and he said yes um
to me in person
and uh in the princeton airport
the 100
cost share will cover assistance for
debris removal emergency protective
measures and direct federal assistance
that is going to be a huge amount of
money
and that's going to free up other
dollars for us
for the months and the years to come
it's going to give us the tools we
require
to help
and to dig out
you know in
mayfield there was something therapeutic
about not only
having the streets been cleared
which they have been
but actually watching
and i saw this in bremen ii
the chaos the devastation
being put into a dump truck and taken
out of town that was special in mayfield
we're not seeing um as much yet in
dawson i know it's picking up
and this is going to help cover all of
that
you know i look forward in the weeks to
come
when while we won't have rebuilt
that people can walk down their streets
without rubble
on the sidewalk where they can get a
better
picture
of what things can look like as we move
forward um whether it was yesterday's
visit for this new 100 percent coverage
federal government has done absolutely
everything that we have asked them to do
and we've asked for some things that
um were hard for them to say yes
on
got a number of other updates um just a
few more pieces that director dosset
will cover on the hundred percent
um
eligible applicants are not only state
government uh but local government uh as
well
it's funded through the public
assistance grant program after 30 days
the cost share reverts to the 2 75-25 i
can guarantee you we're going to be
asking for something different
uh there when we reach it
in other great news fema is all around
uh i think between what they have
helping us in frankfurt and on the
ground there over 700
uh people i think it's one of the
biggest most robust responses
that we have seen and they are walking
house to house
so
houses aren't standing
and um
and already
processing claims
online and i'll go how to do it or with
people walking around we've already have
5500 registrations in the system
and i can't believe this but they've
already made payments from fema
we've got at least 550 000 that have
gone out the door we're on day six
uh there will be millions that go out
the door but it is incredible i i
i was surprised when i heard this
morning that money is already going out
the door that is really special
let's show the slide about ways that you
can sign up for disaster assistance and
director dosset's going to go over this
again
first there's disaster assistance dot
gov
that's available 24 7. we've seen
significant sign ups on it it can be
used to register for disaster assistance
but also to check your application
status which you can in real time
okay there is a slide that goes through
the three different ways
to do it
one is the
hold on just a second
we'll go over the second part if you
can't get online you can call these
numbers 1-800-621-3362
or
1-800-621 fema it's available 7 a.m to 1
00 a.m monday through sunday live agents
are available to help you begin your
claim they will help you
over the phone
and then there is the fema mobile app
that you can download it's available 24
7. you can get it through both the apple
app store and google play it can be used
to register for disaster assistance
check application status and you can
even upload different documents
that you would need
additionally
fema has
registration intake centers open so
you can go online
disasterassistance.gov
you can call these phone numbers
you can also download the app
you can talk to a person walking through
the neighborhood they all have ipads
they're taking the pictures that you
would otherwise have to take if they're
there or you can go to any of these
locations
in hopkins county
the fema mobile registration intake
center is at 960 industrial park road
it's in dawson springs it's 8 a.m to 5
p.m and and that's because there's a
curfew there this is when people can
come in
and help people
in graves county it is at
1102 paris road in mayfield again 8 a.m
to 5
pm
muhlenberg county i think we're going to
be able to handle through the canvassing
it's a small town hit really hard um
i'd say i i was really impressed
um by the mayor like my curtis or county
judge who i've known forever former
sheriff
um
their fire department and everybody else
i mean they've got
so many people out there helping other
people it was really special to see
and in warren county it is at 2 5 6 5
russellville road in bowling green 8 a.m
to 5 p.m on social media we will get a
listing
of those locations up
all right as an update on our state
parks we have opened them up to take our
people in and as uh as we walked around
as brittany um who's over here i keep
looking over
um
walked around both
question we'd always ask people is where
are you staying
um
and if they were sleeping on somebody's
couch we were telling them come to our
state park and let us take care of you i
got to speak to some people that are out
at penny rile and
um
i said they're taking great care of
everybody out there so we announced that
our state parks would provide a minimum
stay of two weeks for anybody displaced
by uh these tornadoes and by two weeks i
was trying to make sure that
everybody knew they didn't need to
to to worry about tomorrow today we're
extending that minimum to four weeks and
the very least we'll house you a month
and listen if there's somebody who has a
reservation whose house has power and
they're warm if we have to we'll cancel
their reservation for those of you that
um
that don't have
that warm home to go home to right now
right now we are housing 610
displaced kentuckians and 176 first
responders we do have room for some more
we have nine rooms available in kentucky
dam village they've got 89 displaced
kentuckians and 155 first responders
ken lake we have 12 rooms available
we've got 146 displaced kentuckians and
eight first responders there at lake
barkley we have one room available
that's got 212 displaced kentuckians 13
first responders this is where we moved
an entire
shelter
there i think when when um secretary
berry first uh contacted the minister he
he he thought it must be a scam because
we were going to take in that many
families and and provide them stable
housing pretty special and i want to
thank that congregation
for helping those people
at barron river like we have 40 rooms
available they're helping 21 displaced
kentuckians james
john james audubon four rooms available
helping nine displaced kentuckians hey
any raw we have one room available which
must have opened up i mean somebody's
got kim that have taken them in we have
129
um
displaced kentuckians
we got a lot uh going on out there which
is pretty special at pennyrile the
police department for the city of morgan
field coordinated a gifts and a santa
visit i think they're going to see santa
more than a few times at our state parks
and a special thanks to t-mobile for
donating cell phones with 30 days of
unlimited talk text and internet uh
sinking fork church also provided
lunches for families out there
then at rough river dam state resort
park we got 44 rooms available we're
currently housing four displaced
kentuckians um
i think that we got a lot of volunteers
too that are out there these aren't just
our state employees taking care of folks
we got
as many folks as we have asked for that
have come and helped out
a little bit on on some other pieces
on the transportation cabinet side we
believe most all roads in every
displaced area are now cleared enough to
get through
just from graves county alone the
transportation cabinet has has taken
1300 loads out of mayfield
uh there's more than 600 transportation
employees
working hard on this every day division
of forestry still out there with 29
employees doing the sawing work and two
bulldozers helping out our national
guard presence
now over 600 deployed i think it's about
530 531
in the impacted counties our mission is
changing
it's now primarily
augmenting law enforcement preventing
looting
and if you are somebody out there that
would even consider
looting someone's home that's lost
everything uh shame on you we will find
you we will arrest you it's absolutely
despicable
um
they're also doing wellness checks uh
and helping with with traffic
uh control over 1200 state employees and
guard combined uh in these areas
uh ksp on the grounds in the areas about
a hundred
um
and and they are verifying and
accounting uh for people who are missing
thus far they verified and accounted for
90
of the employees from the mcp candle
factory and right now the information
that the company has given us is correct
that would suggest just eight loss in
that factory which
is a miracle
is an absolute miracle um
in this disaster i will tell you i was
almost certain that the number would be
70
but thank god
others are left or or escaped
it was feared much much worse
absolute miracle ksps continues to
conduct welfare checks on behalf of
family members and loved ones
for
okay
ksp is asking
and we don't need that
ksp continues to use rapid dna
technology to assist in the
identification of victims
again we need any family members of
missing persons to come to where they're
doing this his house ministries between
10 a.m and 5 p.m
today any day to submit dna
okay
a couple other things on on helping
people with services
i signed an executive order
waiving fees for disaster victims
needing to replace lost operator
licenses permits and state id cards that
means there will be no fees as we are
able to replace those
transportation cabinet will be setting
up temporary credential issue and
station this is going and getting your
your permits and your licenses in
mayfield at three five five charles
drive so you need that driver's license
replaced your real id replaced three
five five charles drive two pop-up
drivers licensing units will be ready by
8 am monday december 20th and will
operate each business day through the
first week of january also we will have
a temporary driver's licensing station
in dawson springs when the when the
location
is identified
no transportations hauling food and
water from fema to impacted areas
again all state routes are passable 70
percent of county and city routes in and
around mayfield are now passable so a
very good job there
we have a lot of different power numbers
i'm going to let michael dossett give
his
in a minute
it's really hard though because we can
restore the main power lines but then
there are still so many
that are out there the tva has been
doing
really good work their overall power
system remains stable and secure
they have restored power to 18 customer
connection points
western kentucky rural electric
cooperative murray electric system
benton electric service glasgow electric
plant board lexington electric service
that's in tennessee pennyrial rural
electric cooperative and gibson electric
membership
corporation still working on mayfield
but just because you are able to restore
power to those cooperatives
still the connection points between them
and houses in many places has to be
um
rebuilt
looks like they've got at least 21 crews
160 individuals out there with more
contractors
than that
team western kentucky relief fund
now um 15.9 million dollars
with over 93 000 donations
we are providing the first set of funds
which are going out the door to cover
funeral expenses nobody has to apply um
we're contacting the individuals
directly
one of the next areas we're going to
look which is really important is how we
can help
some uninsured
homeowners
if you know dawson springs
like i do or mayfield like others do in
these and other areas
it hit neighborhoods of people that were
already struggling to get by
and it's not that
they didn't want to have homeowners
insurance it's that they couldn't afford
it
and so we're going to look at using this
fund to to help because
the individual assistance from fema
we're going to look for all different
sources is capped at 37
900
and that can go if you're insured above
your insurance but for those that don't
have it that's not going to be enough to
rebuild
so we're going to look at how we can
augment
[Music]
those families with
with this fund
those that are already struggling um
shouldn't be struggling more after this
thing is over with what they have
already gone through
i tell you what we got we got a couple
of other updates on unemployment
insurance and others but after that
brittany i think we could use some
really good news if you'll continue to
update us on how these kids who've been
through the worst are going to have the
very best christmas in the history of
kentucky
afternoon
as first lady i was left speechless at
the heartbreaking images of entire
communities left grieving after this
natural disaster
but as a mother
my heart ached especially for those
youngest kentuckians among us
for whom the holidays are particularly
magical time of the year
so on monday this week i announced we're
teaming up with our number one partner
santa claus
who's going to help us launch the
western kentucky toy drive
it's an effort to collect new unwrapped
toys books games electronics and 25 visa
or mastercard gift cards
for the children of western kentucky
this morning i visited broadbent arena
in louisville
which is our largest donation hub
i was overwhelmed
and left speechless
it's incredible the way that people have
responded to this call
i was delighted to be able to help load
some of the boxes
with toys that had been donated
there were volunteers there who um there
was one
elderly woman who had gone yesterday to
drop off toys
and she's still there she is still
helping
to unload and sort toys
just while we were there i think three
trucks full of amazon deliveries showed
up as well as a semi
yeah i i'm speechless these children and
their families just deserve it and it's
it's so heartwarming
so while we are still collecting toys we
have to shift from the collection to the
to the delivery of these items
specifically we are in need of gift
wrapping supplies as well as more 25
dollar visa or mastercard gift cards
and items for older kids and teens like
electronics video games athletic gear
and bikes
and of course books and art supplies are
always needed as well
we will continue to accept donations
until
saturday december 18th if you are able
to contribute please visit
firstlady.ky.gov backslash toy drive
to find the location nearest you
i think it's also important to
remember that every donation counts
it is not too small or too large
there will be a child with joy because
of your thoughtfulness
these tornadoes and the loss they
inflicted would have been devastating
regardless of when they happened
but the proximity to the holidays just
somehow makes it a little
more painful
to everyone who has contributed so far
to the staff and the volunteers who have
made this effort possible
thank you
i may have said this yesterday or the
day before um
as we were learning that tens of
thousands of gifts were coming in and i
i said to brittany um
after christmas this year what are the
parents gonna do next year
and she said to me these kids didn't
just lose their christmas toys andy they
lost all their toys
so
let's shower them in gifts
all right let's turn to uh director
dosset's update and then i've got some
uh things specifically for kentuckians
in the area including uh some assistance
with unemployment since their places of
business will be down but as he's coming
up
i've been asked by businesses
all over the country how they can help
and they have helped in so many
different ways from supplies to
unprecedented amount of dollars let me
just say this
we're going to lose a lot of businesses
in the area and there's going to be a
rebuilding process the number one thing
any company out there can do
is commit to putting up a new facility a
new office
in mayfield
in dawson
in muhlenberg county
these are areas that
we hope the jobs will come back
but you want to talk about providing a
huge ray of hope we can work with you in
economic development but talk about
seeing a brighter future in front of you
so
those looking to help out there that are
already planning
to put some new facility somewhere
really think about the impact that it'll
have on this community
knowing what might be
out there
and available to them
as they get their home back up as they
get their kids back in school
they want to know there's a good job
that they can head to too
director dawson
thank you governor and good afternoon
let's start with the
warning slab first
so
just a little historical reference
you can see the track here of the
tornadoes and these are the main tracks
each one of these colored boxes
are nws warnings and they come in a
variety of different patterns the most
severe are obviously tornado warnings or
severe weather warnings and you can see
the tracks that they have taken these
began and i'm only showing you the
warnings from zero hour which was uh
somewhere around 8 30 p.m
all the way through the end of the storm
track
and during that period alone there were
92 nws warnings put out all over the
state and they range from
radar-indicated tornadoes to severe
weather to squall lines and flash
flooding
so this is the
the impact area and how why this was the
next slide
indicates
some of the tracks and it only indicates
two of the main tracks
uh the national weather service is still
looking at the impact they just upgraded
the main storms three of the main storms
the main track uh was now found to be an
ef uh
four
at 190 miles an hour that is a
remarkably
powerful storm
and as you can see the results from
um all the video and the coverage
of ground zero
moving into
some of the impacts uh that we we are
now we're now working towards
so total decorations there are 23
counties that have declared during the
storm
um
and cities are bowling green cave city
horse cave uh
munfordville park city princeton this is
just a preliminary list and these are
just the data that we have in the system
right now the search and rescue efforts
have moved from
concentrated efforts to wide area
searches and this is just to ensure that
no area has been
left untouched
moving into the power really good news
again and i've talked about this during
all of the briefings
the power company is extraordinarily
efficient at restoring power it is just
the conditions they find when they enter
the state so currently we have
only power outages at 3 280 connections
i will
tell you that 2 000 of those services
cannot be restored and they will not be
restored for weeks and weeks and that's
a very small area and most of it is
ground zero uh in mayfield and some in
dawson springs but it's a very low
number that will still struggle with and
the generators uh will certainly be an
option
the u.s army corps of engineers has
installed the
generator it's a large generator at
dawson springs and that's working
well
we also have good news with
water and power systems
uh there are about 2 600 service
connections with customers at about 18
000 that only have boil water advisories
we have a bit of good news
and it comes slowly but it's coming
in dawson springs water treatment plant
at 11 a.m this morning it was totally
restored to power and that's a big
celebration
next slide on cost
share please
so just a little bit about
the relationship and the partnership
between
governor bashir and the president
we've talked about this the day of the
event we were
recipients of an emergency declaration
the second day
we received an expedited declaration the
third day we added an additional 20
counties and as we moved through the
president's visit
the paperwork was signed
at the state level and sent up
through the fema level but had not
reached the president yet and he
verbally declared after he sought
permission from
direct administrator criswell the bottom
line is this is unprecedented response
he cut through the red tape and governor
beshear pushed it the entire way
the 100 cost share
is an unusual declaration it is not
uncommon in hurricane events and some
tornado events it lasts for 30 days it
is an immediate
opportunity to get reimbursement for 30
days and it
involves one of the largest expenses and
one of the largest reimbursement
opportunities for this entire disaster
and that's does that that's debris
removal
along with emergency medical uh
emergency
protective measures
so fema's in the on the ground
in our hardest hit counties they
currently have 400 personnel on the
ground across the commonwealth in all of
the counties that have been hit
and they're expanding that footprint
they're probably be
by early next week they'll be 700 folks
of all federal teams fema is not the
only team on the ground
and just to name a few of those
it is
the usda the environmental protection
agency
uh the department of defense including
the army corps of engineers the
department of energy and the federal law
enforcement bureau
we're getting
opportunities and responses from the
entire federal umbrella and that's
important to remember
we have requested and been granted
what's called a delta food package this
is 30 000
30 000 meals per day
delivered
every three days
uh and this is the daily output of uh
what a a large area disaster uh and
those are being allocated in most of our
major cities so this will go on this
request
is has been filed and will go on for 30
days
fema also has opened the mobile
registration centers the governor talked
to you about those locations
and there are three uh there are three
ways you can register uh certainly
online a telephone number and then the
mobile centers uh will be announced
we're not giving out all the locations
currently it takes uh it takes a few
days for them to travel from other parts
of the country we'll be putting
many of those mobile centers into the
impacted areas and we'll publish a
schedule as soon as it's available
so fema is also providing us
tarps
cots generators
infant kits and pandemic shelter along
with water basically what happens during
this process is fema ships from atlanta
are one of their large warehouse areas
down to campbell or wendell ford we then
take uh possession of the commodity and
then we move it to a county staging area
and they distribute it in pods it's a
very
it's a very succinct process it works in
every disaster so that is is currently
underway we have 10 shelters now open
they have about 500
500 of our citizens in there the red
cross has provided more than 40 products
to hospitals in the impact areas uh the
rubicon slide please
so this is a um
a success effort and this is the roofing
slide
um
team rubicon responds to disasters all
over the nation they respond to state
requests and have done so a number of
times but this is uh an unusual request
for them because
uh jeff byrd is their co
we're good friends from the time that
jeff was in
leadership in fema he's taken over this
position he actually goes on site the
long and the short of it is they have
tarping crews uh in
our major areas right now they're in
dawson they're in mayfield and they're
in um bowling green so this is just a uh
a photo of one of their crews they do
two types of tarping one is an emergency
roof tarping where you'll see them cover
the roof as they're doing now and the
other is salvage tarping
rain's coming and what they do is they
essentially help the
homeowner gather all their belongings
and then they tarp all the belongings
because many of these residences that
were on cartilage of the main impact
area where the entire home is destroyed
those that are on the edge have varying
different levels of damage and that
includes open rafters
that
some of them can't take tarps so they'll
go in and protect all the uh the
belongings for temporary periods and
they tarp it all and then wrap it
doing great job
so team
rubicon will be moving to other counties
as we move on we also have heavy
equipment teams out there along with cut
and toss teams
that clear debris
so i'll talk a little bit about emac
support emac is the emergency management
assistance compact every state is a
member we have requested emac teams from
a number of our state partners this is a
routine operation
quite frankly in the past in
most of the years that i've been here
we are the state that is sending teams
outbound to other states in need uh in
our region are on
um
on on both coasts
in this
opportunity obviously we have a need
we've advertised emac missions and we
currently have eight teams responding to
the commonwealth some are on the ground
we have imt teams from florida
we also have a volunteer assistance
liaison and that's for donations that
will be doing the state overview for
donations and commodities we have teams
coming from south carolina that will
will do emac management from us
and additional teams for
donation support
the national guard is on the ground
obviously and they're doing debris
removal
law enforcement augmentation and traffic
control and security across our impact
counties
so i'd like to finish up with the last
slide uh you know there is always some
additional problematic news during
disasters this one involves weather
that's inbound
so we're looking at a weather event over
western kentucky and it includes the
mayfield area they're experiencing
moderate and light showers right now to
6 pm heavy rain begins at
2 a.m friday morning and it goes all the
way
through 10 a.m
and you can see the the outputs there
the initial part of it is uh up to fifth
uh
up to a half of an inch and uh through
sunday morning all the way through the
three-day period is up to two inches
that's not what we want but there's a
lot of tarpon
operations going on
and that concludes my update for today
thank you governor
you know it's not right the people
who've had their homes knocked down and
are trying to salvage it or now having
all this rain on top of it it's
not right
all right other ways that um
we're looking to help people
disaster unemployment assistance
application we have sent to the u.s
department of labor it is pending
approval
uh field locations for uh ui services
because
people aren't going to have a place to
go to to work in many instances for a
while
are being established in mayfield that's
at the walmart location so the mayfield
walmart the mccracken county library the
trigg county library the butler county
library the hardin county library in
bowling green we're directly in the gm
plant
four staff started working there on
december the 15th and we're looking at
further coordinating locations with fema
for better services and deliveries
the teams established are ready to go uh
pending final approvals from the federal
government and we're hoping to
streamline the id verification process
to facilitate claims and get payments
i'm going to be working on getting a
waiver
for the waiting week because they'd have
to wait a week
wouldn't get paid from anywhere if their
employer has had to
to lay them on as well as work search
requirements for at least a portion of
the coming weeks or months because we
want them to rebuild in that area we
don't want them to leave mayfield or
dawson or freeman
and so now these are steps that we need
to take they'll likely have to be done
by executive order in the short term
okay
um
kentucky occupational and health
compliance staff is in mayfield to
address
worker safety and health issues waging
our compliance staff are going to be
working with usdol for anything
that arises department of workers claims
is identified and spoken with two
insurers that will be involved with the
workers compensation claims related to
the candle factory both are accepting
claims and thus far are responsive to
those claims
total insurance claims reported as of 10
am today
9145
it's hard to estimate how many
folks are also
uninsured and remember those we have
both homeowners and renters
that would be potentially insured or
uninsured for the value of their home
and their belongings or what is um
in their
uh apartments or or for rental units
there is the same amount of assistance
generally for renters uh as there is for
homeowners from fema um and in fact
there are situations where you may
qualify for both depending on what your
timeline looks like on rebuilding
but department of insurance response
teams are being set up in grace hopkins
warren and muhlenberg
we will update once that comes online
they're going to make sure that these
insurance companies are treating people
fairly
let's see i believe that maybe
oh no we got a couple of other
again things we're trying to do to help
people so this week
we were also
able following the federal
disaster declaration to get the irs to
extend the 2021 tax filing and other
deadlines from april 15 to may 16th and
our kentucky department of revenue will
honor this special tax relief for
individuals and households affected by
the severe storms tornadoes and flooding
who reside or have a business in
caldwell fulton graves hopkins marshall
muhlenberg taylor and warren that'll
allow affected taxpayers until may 16th
to file their income taxes and submit
payments for individual income tax
corporate income tax uh their
withholding or the limited liability
entity tax i mean certain deadlines
quarterly payments as well as
the one for 2021 income tax returns will
be postponed for the affected taxpayers
again
i mean at a time like this you can't
expect people to have the documentation
needed and so we're extending those
deadlines
uh the president's federal disaster
declaration also makes kentuckians in
those eight counties eligible for a
refund of kentucky sales and use tax
paid on the purchase of building
materials permanently installed in the
repair or replacement of structure
damages in the eight counties covered by
the disaster declaration so as
rebuilding
if
you were directly paying for building
supplies make sure you document those
you could get up to six thousand dollars
in relief from sales tax per uh building
um
we'll put this out by a separate press
release
where we're increasing
and this is within the state to
qualified residential treatment care
programs that serve children that have
been struggling uh during covet uh these
are are are places like uh like
maryhurst and others
we have found a way to
increase
the the funds that are provided to them
to help them
as they are making it through
this pandemic
some were struggling so much
they were looking at shutting down we'll
have the direct information
in the release
we are
hurting we're still hurting
and it continues to be very painful
but we are not broken
we are not broken
even when it feels like it
we will
we will
clear this chaos and and death from our
towns
and we will rebuild our structures and
our lives
and just like every person i talked to
yesterday the day before the day before
that the day before that including on
saturday
i'm not going anywhere and this state is
not going anywhere
we got a great commitment from the
federal government that they're going to
be with us too
every step
every week
every month and every year that it takes
we will get each one of these
communities rebuilt this is very
personal to me
and we're going to make sure that it
happens
all right with that we'll open it up to
questions i think we have four
journalists here and a bunch on the line
so let's start with tom
thank you governor um
two things something just came to mind
is uh state going to be
developing a website to link all this
information you gave a lot of things
online
we should um
it's a great suggestion um we're we're
building this airplane uh while we're
flying it but we're gonna we we should
centralize all this information what's
available to an individual that's been
through the horrific and then we need to
get it out in in paper too to some of
the facilities out there to to help them
as we move forward as much as we can on
some of this stuff i hope we can set up
in one location it's just there's not
one big location left
in most of these places and there's so
many people helping
i mean
we've got 1200 garden state employees
and you look at 10 000 people and
typically in mayfield and 3 700 in
dawson and 370 and
uh bremen
and then put all the fema people on top
and all the rest we have
we have about as many people helping as
we do that live in these places and god
bless them
my main question was i see you issued an
executive order
on
livestock
yeah so so there is a
statute of regulation about the amount
of time that you have
to
to
do away with
clean up
to destroy
dead livestock
that's primarily dealing with disease
and we think it probably only applies to
that but there was concern that that it
could apply in this situation as well
and
there are
so many
uh
dead livestock
that that we know it's going to take
more time
we are uh listening directly uh to our
our our farmers we know that there's
going to be some long-term needs too is
the farming community
you know where do they get their feet
from who do they typically sell to what
have the losses been there so one of the
early calls i made was that we needed
usda on the ground uh and the federal
government sped up how quickly uh that
happened uh still working through all
the rest of the needs working directly
with judges and and their folks we're
gonna find a solution to every concern
carolina
the number of people missing has
dramatically gone down which is great um
does this
help the state kind of figure out where
our death toll will stand or
so every day that passes
the range of our death toll becomes more
certain and the likelihood that we will
have significantly more death
lessons um i am hearing at least rumors
that we will add one today um and
perhaps someone unexpected um our number
missing requires someone report them
uh missing and and so there may be more
uh that are that are out there i hope
um that
additional deaths that we see will be in
single digits they could come from
people that we find and it could also
come from people who are currently
hospitalized uh though every day that
passes that the number doesn't go up or
go up significantly is a good day all
considered uh certainly as we get uh now
some some pretty close to certainty on
the candle factory um
that means our toll is first much less
than i thought it would be i thought we
were going to lose about as many people
in that factory as we have overall um
so so it's i think i think we're getting
closer and closer to what that final
number will be
uh phil
governor do you have any thoughts about
the litigation that's been filed
at the candle factory the allegations
that workers were forced to work with
the tornado upon them
yeah i know litigation has been filed in
the
in the candle factory but i don't have
any um independent knowledge of any of
the allegations that are there
um
i did see it
and i've never seen
anything like the the the
total wreckage
and steel and and i mean big trucks that
i i say they're on the roof the roof
wasn't there
um
by the time i got there and this is just
how an hour after daylight there must
have been
eight ten twelve it's it's hard when
you're trying to take it in backhoes and
heavy equipment trying to
pull things off of it i mean it um
it's a miracle we only lost eight um i
don't know what happened uh in there
that night i do know it was hit directly
by one of the most powerful tornadoes i
think we'll ever see on record
lawrence first
clarification the 75 number today is
that one more than yesterday
yes it adds that individual in bowling
green that is reported to have had a
heart attack in the in the cleanup
we heard the president's public comments
can you give us some insight into the
private conversations you had about sure
uh
the president
uh was very caring
uh from the moment
uh that he landed i think he he from our
private conversations two things uh
we're clear um
number one that that he genuinely cares
uh and that was evident and and it was
evident when he but his secret service
was trying to get him to go this way and
there was a family over that way and
it was
it was absolutely clear and second
that there is there is a full commitment
by the federal government even to do
things that they've never done before to
help us uh we have gotten a yes on
virtually everything uh that we've asked
for and and the speed at which we've
gotten them is
is incredible so to him to our fema
administrator to our uh
secretary of homeland security uh and
everybody in between um the federal
response could not be
uh better than it has been
uh al cross
thank you governor it was quite an
eventful day yesterday and uh
aside from uh getting 100
federal funding for 30 days
uh what other surprises did you pay it
uh yesterday
uh
so so um
first there were really tough moments
yesterday i had not been able to get
that far back
in dawson springs and it was even worse
than um i could tell and it
it was painful um
but to also see the number of people
that
would say that they are blessed to be
alive
um was was pretty special and remember
in this i mean eight blocks in any
direction nothing standing everybody
that is
sorting through the rubble knows
uh each other and you know it's uh
i said before just i mean the trauma
kind of seeps into your skin
but i will say that having the president
uh there and and especially in mayfield
uh created an energy
and you know what i was just happy for
one day
because it had been what five or six
days for just
one day
since this happened that there seemed to
be this really positive energy the the
the president of the united states was
there i'm not sure i expected
to feel that um and you could see it on
people's faces
there's a woman who said he's in
mayfield
and i think that was
that was the feeling you know whether or
not you voted for him or he voted for
for for me um
we're both trying to do our very best
for you and and i could absolutely uh
see that
the president coming to mayfield in the
dawson springs i never thought
i said yesterday i never thought i'd get
to introduce the president of the united
states i never thought i'd get him to
dawson springs but by god i wish it was
for um
for different reasons
uh jack brammer herald leader
yes a governor of the 138 kentuckians
injured
where did most of them occur do you have
a county by county breakdown of the
injured and do you know how many were
injured in the mayfield
candle factory
uh i think that
the last number i had is that there were
17 people hospitalized
from the the mayfield uh candle
factory i do not have the and that was
yesterday i think i got that information
if i got it the day before i apologize
it's all
um
it's been a lot uh the last couple of
days um
generally uh hopkins county area 21 of
those i think we had one person and
kenton and logan um graves county area
we we it's so so people would be
transferred
um probably two
[Music]
um
24 those would be there 26
52-ish
i think in the in the graves county
extended area those include hospitals
in
in paducah
uh taylor regional
had at least 12
who were there if not 13 one in
frankfurt here you know one in
georgetown five in owensboro so this
made impacts
in different places well let me back up
uh 22 are down at vanderbilt
um and six
um in in union city tennessee so
and add another 30 on to so over a
hundred from graves county i think is is
what we're pretty close to though
hopkins and graves are close enough to
where
um you could also be transferring some
people who are who are hurting dawson
down to
down the vanderbilt
that's the best i can do jack
uh karen's r
thank you governor governor could you
talk a little bit more about
unemployment there are already people
online who are worried saying
they're afraid they're going to end up
in some endless loop like we saw in the
pandemic is there anything you could say
to ease their concerns
thank you uh i'm gonna say i'm gonna say
that we're gonna have people in person
in each of these counties processing
your claims in front of you we're gonna
get it done
we're absolutely going to get it done
uh piper hudsmith blackburn associated
press
hello um thank you governor um my
question has to do with cleanup
um
is karen stark so i still
can you hear me i don't see much i can
hear you
i can hear you okay good um
yeah so how long is this initial stage
of cleanup supposed to last and what do
you say to those
that those kentuckians who sort of feel
like the damage is insurmountable and it
might last forever like
um
thank you well
yeah the the cleanup is going to take
time depending on the structure uh that
we're talking about and
if you've seen it it'll it'll take at
least weeks uh if we can do it in weeks
it will be incredible i believe that
we'll be hauling debris
out of some of these locations for up to
a month
director yep
any other thoughts okay director dawson
so thank you for the question um this is
going to be one of the largest
pieces of the recovery uh in fact as i
leave this briefing i'm going back into
a meeting with fema and our our our
other federal partners to flesh out the
reef removal plan we're going to hold
webinars in the next days possibly one
tomorrow we'll announce that
debris removal is one of the most
important pieces because this this is
part and parcel to rebuilding not just
uh the city infrastructure but for all
of our homeowners so you'll hear more
about this but again
please allow us to manage expectations
this is a long long recovery and the
process to put all the programs on the
road as you can see from
the governor's relationship with the
president
the actual
personnel are on the ground immediately
and they're all working in that
direction so we're moving very quickly
the plan will be announced very shortly
and then
after the plan is announced
counties and the state and the federal
government will all come together
there'll be contractors that each county
can engage we also have federal assets
and state assets that are working toward
that
from being on the ground it also depends
on which which place we're talking about
bremen had uh dump trucks up and down
the road they were able to bring in from
muhlenberg county already loading up a
huge death toll
given the population of the area fewer
structures overall
uh in the city their their their debris
removal is going to go a lot faster
than
dawson which is huge numbers of homes
mayfield which is huge numbers of homes
and really big government buildings
so it is
it is um
ongoing uh and and a lot of it will
depend on the level of resources as they
continue we're going to have every
resource from the state we're going to
have every resource from the federal
government we've got a lot of great
volunteers that are out there right now
too
debbie yetter courier journal
from the governor uh if i could ask
about coleman 19 for a minute
i am uh with cope with omnicron
spreading rapidly in more than 30 states
now has it been identified in kentucky
and are you all worried about spread in
this area affected by the tornado with
people possibly more crowded together
routines disrupted and so forth
yes worried about spread
in the area of the tornado one of the
reasons we're trying to get people out
of a shelter and into a state park is we
can create a little more distance we can
also give them a room of their own i
have not been
notified of our first case of uh omicron
but it's here um it's unquestionably
here uh it's it's already everywhere and
and the speed is significant uh that it
doubles in the the question of what it's
going to lead to
uh all depends on the level of infection
and some questions that we don't yet
know
uh first they're trying to figure out
exactly how
much faster it spreads than delta it
appears to spread faster and how
resistant it is to what level of
vaccination so those are two questions
for how many people will get it
other set of questions is how sick does
it make you
because you know it can it can still do
a lot of damage even if it makes you
happy sick but infects twice as many
people and so it's going to be
those two levers that that will
ultimately um um
tell us where we're going um also uh the
amount of of therapeutics um
and and vaccinations and boosters we're
getting right now will impact that as
well i mean it looks like you've had
both shots in a booster if you get uh
that you're less likely to get it and if
you get it you're probably gonna be okay
i can't imagine that having both shots
uh won't put you in a better place if
you get it about how sick you get in
whatever spectrum
of of how
deadly or how sick
that it makes you if you are
unvaccinated
you've probably gone through delta it's
been awful and it looks like this thing
can come right
along behind it and re-infect you so i
mean please get vaccinated
if you've had delta i hope
uh that it that it provides some level
of immunity to you but after what you've
been through why in the world risk that
if you can get a series of
shots that ultimately help you out
karen boyer weku
hi governor you mentioned a couple of
challenges authorities are facing like
fema going door-to-door to houses that
are no longer standing and the need for
family members of people who are missing
to submit dna
how are authorities responding to those
challenges and then there's some concern
among communities about
people who are undocumented staying in
state parks is that a concern they
should have thank you
anybody who lost their home
we want to have a place to stay
listen i i
if if somebody has got kids
and and all of a sudden have absolutely
no place to stay i want them to have a
roof
over their head so we're going to help
people out at state parks
that lost their home
uh how we're responding to the to the
challenges we continue to spread the
word which is the main way
to family members and across the region
um spreading it across the state is
really helpful too as they check
uh on people
uh the his house ministries
not only can they can also take phone
calls uh about missing individuals as
can sheriff's offices and others uh
throughout the the region uh so you know
we we just we we know there are likely
some other folks out there we want to
know about as many of them as possible
most likely that person that you think
is missing is okay
but we can connect you uh to them what
was the other challenge
i will get you we'll get you a an
additional response if you need one
uh han assad the paducah son
thank you governor um i was just
speaking with some of the residents in
mayfield and i was wondering if there's
any statewide initiative to help folks
who maybe lost their cars or don't have
ways to get out to resources if they
live kind of far away is there any
statewide are you aware of any private
organizations that are providing
transportation assistance
we're working on that piece um you know
in the in the first several days our
goal was safety security
planning
but but yes transportation is going to
be important
if you see what this thing did to cars
they're most likely not going to be
salvageable either i do know that there
are adjusters um if you are insured that
are on site that are there we do want to
try to streamline that though uh for
people
and then you know we've had folks
reaching out about other things that
they can do to help um we're going to be
trying to to connect some of those
resources certainly we can title a new
or a used vehicle for folks as they
replace it at any of these facilities
that we're setting up i mean these folks
don't have a driver's license likely um
their their last car title they're going
to need to turn it in um they're going
to need a a new one as well so you know
that point's well taken and and
transportation right now we've used
school buses to get people from shelters
to state parks last question grace
mckenna whas 11.
sorry about that governor um i'd like to
give it back to covid for a quick moment
if we could um you know coming up on the
holiday season i know we were all
concerned about surges during the
holidays last year could you talk about
the role of the booster um you know in
helping to prevent some of those surges
especially as we see omicron starting to
spread inevitably to kentucky
christmas is supposed to be
a wonderful special time where we
celebrate uh a life
and and life
itself salvation what is good in mankind
uh the hope
and then we we have a new year uh where
we make resolutions to be uh better
where where there are uh new chances
they are supposed to be
wonderful
hopeful
life affirming
holidays and last year they were deadly
we lost a lot of kentuckians
through the spread
covet 19 during those holidays
this year we don't have to
last year
you couldn't be fully vaccinated
or it would have been very hard to be
fully vaccinated by christmas this year
everybody can be and this year we have a
booster as well because waning immunity
is real i believe the
largest single factor and what type of
surge that we are going to see
over the holidays and and into the
beginning of the year is how many people
get their booster if you do it you're
pretty well protected you'll free up uh
that hospital capacity
if it comes in a crunch that others will
need so please
for the holiday season if you haven't
gotten vaccinated go get vaccinated even
if it's your first shot go ahead and get
it it'll help
if you've been fully vaccinated and it's
time for your booster go get it don't
wait until after the holidays go get it
as quickly as you can
and then just think about the way you're
you're holding your holiday gathering if
everybody is vaccinated if everybody is
boosted and those that aren't
really consider masks while you're
inside and close together that protects
everyone and maybe just have a slightly
smaller gathering than you did last year
listen
we can do that safely
we can wear a mask in a gathering if
it's needed
we can we can have a slightly smaller
gathering because you know what
we're pretty blessed especially when you
look at a whole bunch of people that
don't have homes
in western kentucky so you know
everybody just try to protect one
another and we've seen
horrific loss of life we've seen
destruction
at a level
nobody has ever seen so
i see the outpouring of love
take care of each other and um
we'll uh we'll continue to update on um
on services on on loss of life and on
how we are going to dig out we're not
broken we will rebuild and we'll get
through it and we'll get through it
together thank you
you